à paris ils étaient entre 500 et 1000
robe noire pour réclamer davantage de
moyens pour la justice comment ce
mouvement at il débuté neuf magistrats
ont tout d'abord publié une tribune dans
le monde signé depuis par plus de 7500
magistrat sur les neuf mille que compte
la france c'est dire comme les
magistrats sont unanimes dans leurs
revendications
la tribune relate et la souffrance d'une
jeune fille du nord juge charlotte âgée
de 29 ans elle était éprouvé par ces
lourds horaires travailler les week-ends
et pendant les vacances et elle a fini
par se suicider après cette plainte de
ces conditions de travail et de sa
souffrance et pourtant le budget de la
justice a connu une hausse de 8% deux
années consécutives mais ce n'est pas
assez
la france n'est qu'au 14e rang sur 27
pays européens au point de vue du budget
et le manque de moyens abouti à un
engorgement des tribunaux à des reports
d'audiences des audiences trop rapide
expéditive les contractuels embauchés ne
reste pas assez pour être pleinement
opérationnel
je vous propose d'écouter des robes
noires ainsi que le député insoumis ugo
bernalicis la souffrance de magistrales
a des répercussions la misère de la
justice ça a des répercussions sur les
gens et sur les justiciables quand vous
attendez 18 mois pour divorcer trois ans
pour voir juger votre licenciement ou 18
mois pour voir juger votre agresseur ça
a des répercussions sur les gens et donc
ce que nous renvoient aussi les
justiciables c'est à dire on comprend
plus et roland se passe rien ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on comprend en pleine
figure que mes collègues prennent en
pleine figure ils n'en sont pas
responsables mais cea qui en demandent
des comptes et ça ça devient
insupportable
donc oui on demande des moyens pour la
justice mais pour la justice pour les
magistrats bien sûr qu'ils sacrifient
bien souvent leur santé et leur vie
privée les manques de moyens ils se
traduisent forcément par des manques
d'effectifs et donc des procédures qui
s'enlise qui durent parfois des années
et c'est pas le service public qu'on
veut rendre aux justiciables des gens
ils viennent vers la justice pour
trouver des solutions pour que leur
litige soit réglé rapidement
efficacement et on se retrouve avec des
procédures qui se termine
des années après et où la peine en qu'en
matière pénale est prononcée
des années après il n'a plus aucun sens
au moment où elle est prononcée c'est
pas comme s'il n'y avait pas eu de loi
sur la justice et la loi de
programmation 2018 2022 là on vient de
voter confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire hier avant-hier par dont on a
voté la lecture définitive
responsabilité pénale et sécurité
intérieure des lois il y en a tous les
quatre matins mais c'est des lois
pourquoi pour créer des nouveaux délits
et donc pour créer à nouveau de
l'activité dans les allées dans les
tribunaux et à la fin ça n'a plus de
rapport avec les besoins réels dans
l'est dans les juridictions donc le
malaise et le mal être il est profond il
n'est pas nouveau c'est sûr mais c'est
un certain c'est un fort signal qui nous
obligent pour cette élection
présidentielle être à la hauteur des
demandes à la fois de la dame et ratures
mais de ce que signifie l'idée de
justice dans un pays où il ya deux jours
le ministre de la justice eric
dupond-moretti semblait satisfait de ce
qui a été fait durant le mandat d'
emmanuel macron expliquant qu'en 2022 le
budget serait de 8,9 milliards d'euros
contre 6 8 milliards d'euros en 2017
mais comme l'ont souligné ici magistrats
et greffiers les fonds supplémentaires
sont principalement fléchés vers le
pénitentiaire est donc pas pour le bon
fonctionnement de la justice